people nowadays often say sometimes in a
sad way other times more aggressively
and cynically that life just has no
meaning two reasons are often given for
this the first has to do with religion
once upon a time so the story goes life
had a clear meaning given to us by God
it was about worshipping Him
but as religious belief has declined not
only has God supposedly died but along
with him the meaning he was guaranteed
modern science is the second cause of
the current crisis of meaning scientists
tell us that life which emerged from a
random interplay of chemicals and gases
does have meaning but it's of a rather
bleak lent less and narrow sort for
humans as for all other living things
like amoeba the meaning of life is
survival and the propagation of one's
genetic material it sounds very true and
at the same time distinctly futile and
melancholy here we want to argue as
follows to wonder about the meaning of
life is an extremely important activity
life does have substantial meaning and
there are in fact a range of practical
steps we can take to ensure we end up
leading lives of maximal meaningfulness
we should start by saying that there is
no meaning in life outside of that which
we can find by ourselves as a species
there isn't any kind of objective
meaning written in the stars in a holy
book or in sequences of DNA what seems
to prompt people to complain that life
lacks meaning a particular varieties of
unhappiness
let's consider some central examples
you're in a relationship but the
intensity you experienced at the start
has long gone you don't seem to talk
about anything important anymore or
share vulnerable feelings and ideas it
feels as you put it meaningless or else
you're single and though you have many
friends every time you see them the
conversation seems shallow and trivial
or you're at university studying for a
degree you signed up for the course in
part because you often feel confused
about who you are and what you want
you thought that reading books and going
to lectures would shine a light on
things but the topics are dull and
disconnected from your confusion you've
complained that it feels meaningless or
you're working in a large profitable
company and earning a decent sum
every week but the work doesn't seem in
the grander scheme important by which
you mean two things that you don't seem
to be making any great difference to
anyone's life and also that there's no
profound part of you that you're able to
bring to or incorporate in your work it
might as well be done by a robot from
these strands we can start to
extrapolate a theory of meaning meaning
is to be found in three activities in
particular communication understanding
and service let's look at communication
first we are by nature isolated
creatures and it appears that some of
our most meaningful moments are to do
with instances of connection with a
lover for example when we reveal our
intimate physical and psychological
selves or when we form friendships where
substantial truths about our respective
lives can be shared or on a journey to a
new country when we strike up a
conversation with a stranger and feel a
thrilling sense of victory over
linguistic and cultural barriers then
there's the meaning that emerges via
understanding this is about the pleasure
that can be felt whenever we correct
confusion and puzzlement about ourselves
or the world we might be scientific
researchers or economists poets or
patients in psychotherapy the pleasure
of our activities stems from a common
ability to map and make sense of what
was once painfully unfamiliar and
strange thirdly there's service one of
the most meaningful things we can do is
to serve other people to try to improve
their lives either by alleviating
sources of suffering or else by
generating new sources of pleasure that
includes medical professionals but also
people who bake cakes write songs or
dance for a living we're often told to
think of ourselves as inherently selfish
but some of the most meaningful moments
come when we can transcend our egos and
put ourselves at the service of others
or the planet one should add that in
order for service to feel meaningful it
has to be in sync with our own native
sincere interests it's a case of knowing
enough about ourselves to find our
particular path to service armed with
such ideas we can move towards defining
nothing less than the meaning of life
the meaning of life is to pursue human
flourishing through calm
negation understanding and service we
may not have meaningful lives yet but
it's central to affirm that the concept
of a meaningful life is eminently
plausible and that it comprises elements
that can be clearly named and gradually
fought for